how to reach students who do not have
internet access it is a question eight
news and i was trying to find the answer
to
as families prepare for distance
learning come august 24th
all five days of the week the nevada
state board of education met today to
discuss this
important issue kirsten joyce joins us
live from her home anchoring studio
and kirsten there is still a lot of work
to be done to make sure students are
ready
yeah there certainly is brian my
goodness talk about that they've got a
month left and a lot has to be figured
out within that time
even with today's meeting not a lot of
solutions came out of it but there are
some strong directives from nevada state
board of education president elaine wynn
to get the situation resolved
this is really in a sense setting up the
infrastructure
of the 21st and 22nd century uh you know
we it's like railroads we we can't exist
in going forward in a digital world uh
with pockets that are not connected so
now is the time i guess brought
forth by this pandemic for us to
acknowledge
we've got to get connected
this past spring ccsd distributed more
than 60 000 chromebooks during closures
it also established more than a dozen
bus routes that allowed students to
access wi-fi
that effort has to be ramped up ccsd
says 128 000 households
don't have internet and while 100 000
are expected to be subsidized by the cox
program that leaves about 28 000 kids
remaining
and don't forget the teachers board
members brought up the fact that they
too
need suitable devices to conduct their
lessons well earlier this week we
learned nevada attorney general aaron
ford will also help school districts
with the t-mobile project 10 million
initiative
it will provide internet services for
free to students enrolled in the
national school lunch program
and important to keep in mind as well
part of that program also provides
students with reduced cost devices